let's go to logan from san jose
california logan you're on the air
hi uh can you hear me all right yes i
can thanks david
i'm also from the bay area so i'll make
up for the last person beautiful
um my question is on the
joe biden's covid relief bill yes i
noticed
there was the 15 minimum wage added in
there i'm kind of wondering the purpose
of that
because it doesn't seem like now is the
right time with small businesses already
looking to make payroll or
not being able to make payroll and uh it
seems like it's only going to slow down
a
time-sensitive bill you know i didn't
see that let me
see um let's see here biden stim
i didn't know that that was part of
biden's
stimulus let me take a look i'm pulling
up an article about that
biden called for a rescue package of 1.9
trillion
and we have all of the the things
increasing the federal minimum wage to
15
per hour oh that's interesting you know
it's not it's not clear to me
that he's calling for that to be in the
bill and quite frankly i don't even know
if you can do it that way
uh but i'd have to look into that more
that's it's an interesting question i
didn't think i thought he was saying
part of my economic plan is a 15 minimum
wage i didn't think he wanted that
literally in the coveted rescue bill
okay uh you know i admittedly didn't
look uh too closely at it i thought it
was a part of it but
i i'm not 100 sure right i know it was
part of his presentation but
that's a really good question whether
you would include a minimum wage change
in the bill and listen let me put it
this way
even if he is thinking of putting a
minimum wage of 15
in the coveted relief bill that's going
to be negotiated out
it's not going to get past this part of
covet relief that i can assure you
got it got it um one other quick
question i noticed uh
today in the inaugural address and joe
biden's been really
pushing for for unity you know reaching
across the aisle and uh
between parties i'm wondering what that
what's that gonna look
like in your opinion oh it's a complete
impossibility i i mean i think it's
great that joe biden is using this
language
and to the extent that it will appeal to
voters to hear joe biden say even after
all this i'm everybody's president i
think that's great
um how are you going to have unity with
mitch mcconnell
uh lauren bobert marjorie taylor green
you know there's just no way there's no
it's just not going to happen but i
think
biden's doing the right thing by saying
it because until they
show him they will be obstructionists
biden should go forward saying let's
work together and then we'll see what
happens
yeah that's that's i i wasn't sure how
it was possible yeah
no it's not it's not but it's good for
biden to say it
all right that's all i got for you today
david thanks all right thanks very much
appreciate it
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60
000 masks to healthcare institutions
they're an
excellent company shipping is just five
bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david